sur les plages bretonnes avec le
printemps arrive les marées vertes des
algues qui polluent qui pue est pire
encore tu mets pour s'en rendre compte
il a fallu des décennies observée sur
les plages bretonnes dans les années 60
ces algues appelé ulf gagne du terrain
dans les années 70 et 80
ce qui alerte c'est leur quantité et
leur odeur d'oeuf pourri
ap lester en 1982 l'inquiétude est
d'abord économique
c'est un problème qui qui nous dépasse
actuellement et qui a pris des
proportions énormes en notre commune est
aussi ça nous touche énormément sur le
plan touristique
mais comment prolifèrent ces ulves selon
des études scientifiques c'est à cause
d'une eau riche en nitrates et
phosphates
les chercheurs pensent d'abord à une
pollution domestique dans les années 80
à cause des produits d'entretien mais
ils se rendent compte en 1996 que la
véritable cause c'est de l'agriculture
depuis plus trente ans donc s'est
installé en bretagne l'agriculture
intensive qui a généré des déjections
animales importante qui utilisent
énormément d'engrais et on a réussi à
montrer que la marée verte se développe
parce qu'elles utilisent les sels
nutritifs qu'on trouve dans ces
déjections animales et danser en grec
la prolifération se répète chaque
printemps et inquiète davantage en cause
un gaz dégagé par les algues en
putréfaction l'hydrogène sulfuré déjà
suspecté en 1989 dans le décès d'un
homme
il est à l'origine de la mort par
asphyxie de chiens en 2008 d'un cheval
et d'un autre homme en 2009 réaction du
premier ministre françois fillon un plan
intergouvernementale l'état va prendre
toutes ses responsabilités et va prendre
à sa charge le nettoyage des plages qui
sont les plus touchés c'est à dire de
celles sur lesquelles il peut y avoir un
risque de santé publique
134 millions d'euros sur cinq ans pour
le ramassage la valorisation des algues
en méthane et des aides pour les
agriculteurs qui répandent moins
d'engrais dans les champs mais d'autres
décès surviennent 36 sangliers en 2011
et un joggeur en 2016
la journaliste inès nayrou a enquêté sur
le dossier
elle publie ses travaux en 2017 sous
forme de bande dessinée
elle estime que l'état aurait pu
intervenir plus tôt voilà on a tendance
à accuser les agriculteurs
l'agroalimentaire mon bac et au départ
c'est quand même un programme étatique
une volonté d'industrialiser
l'agriculture et l'état qui n'a pas
voulu entendre les scientifiques lui
disant on est en train d'engendrer des
marées vertes dès les années 80 l'état
qui a fait la sourde oreille qui a passé
cette information sous silence
en 2017 un second plan a été mis en
place pour quatre ans les marées vertes
se répète chaque année avec le
réchauffement des eaux
elles sont plus intenses et gagnent des
territoires jusque là préservées
[Musique]